Joining me today is an activist and
advocate who co founded the student led
gun control advocacy group.
Never again MSD.
He also helped organize the march for
our lives nationwide student protest
earlier this year.
Cameron Caskey.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me.
I'm really happy that you're here for
for many reasons.
Mostly because you strike me suddenly as
someone that's trying to find some
common ground these days and we're gonna
get into that in a whole bunch more.
But,
uh,
of course I have to mention up top you
are a survivor of the parkland shooting
in Florida.
Um,
before we go whole into that and
everything that you've been through
since,
just tell me a little bit about life
before [inaudible].
I assume you have a life before and now
a new life.
Well,
you know,
I spent most of my life as your typical
little shitster who just said whatever
you wanted to have a voice.
I was always so convinced that I was
right about everything.
Whether that was nature and nurture is
kind of up to interpretation,
but I really grew up just dead set on
the fact that I knew everything.
Everything I said was right and I was a
genius.
I learned the hard way recently little
to recently that I'm not and that was a
crazy awakening.
Learning that you don't know everything
in the entire world is actually an
interesting experience,
but one of the things that helped me a
lot was doing theater.
I was a big theater kid because I had
this voice.
I always wanted to express myself.
I was a flippantly loud all the time and
do.
I didn't know what to do with it.
You know?
I was knocking doors for Obama when I
was seven.
Wow.
Yeah.
I was really interested in being active
with all that.
I mean,
I knew nothing.
I thought that John Mccain was running
with Tina Fey,
not Sarah Pailin because I had really
only seen the news and I,
I guess I got it mixed up with seven.
I didn't expect myself to be a policy
expert,
but you know,
again,
I think the point is I was always really
excited to speak and,
and I got involved with drama and drama.
Said,
hey,
you have a voice,
here's the way to use it.
And you learn a lot of lessons from
doing theater.
Have you,
have you ever done anything else,
steve at school?
Not In high school.
I did spend 12 years doing standup
comedy in New York City,
which is a whole other nightmare,
but
I,
um,
I always wanted to do stand up and then
I tried it once when I was seven years
old I was on a cruise with my family and
there was a kind of adults only
nightclub.
It wasn't really you're able to get in
if you were younger,
but I was the only person there under
maybe 40 and they had an open mic and I
kept on,
I kept on raising my hand to get on and
the hosts was saying,
know what the,
what the,
what the hell is this kid doing?
And finally he just caved in and was
like,
all right,
let's let the kid get up here.
And I walked out there and I drop a
three minute routine.
I make a joke about my dad's penis,
which was an interesting experience.
And the thing is I did not know that
while I was sitting alone in the front
row,
I snuck out of my room,
my went to the club and I didn't see
them.
Wow.
So I'm A.
I'm out there,
I'll say it,
I'll send you the,
the clip privately.
I'm out there and I'm four foot three
and,
and everybody's drunk so they think I'm
a riot.
So I think I'm a riot.
And I just kept going and going to the
point where the guy who was running the
open mic was just looming behind me
waiting for me to be done.
But I guess he just didn't want to grab
the mic from a small child without
looking kind of weird.
Stand up is probably best done once.
It's seven years old and never again.
So exactly what you're doing.
Everybody's had their 15 minutes of fame
when they were seven on a cruise.
Yeah.
Alright.
So,
so you were a theater kid.
Um,
anything else we should know about?
Just like high school life,
like high school life for a kid in 2017,
2018,
like what's it like?
I'm,
I'm not that old but I ain't 17 anymore.
Well,
you know,
I,
high school was really fun for me.
I really enjoyed it on a social level.
I was a shitty student.
My test scores were always good,
but my grades were awful because they
never bothered to do homework.
I thought I was too smart and cool for
that.
But um,
I,
I liked high school a lot because I
never really subscribed to one social
circle.
I kind of hung out with a lot of people,
you know,
kids who were the stereotypical popular
kids,
you know,
I was just the guy they knew that was
funny.
I would hang out with that sometimes
kids who were the stereotypical nerds,
we would talk about movies and comic
books,
which I want to get into your comic book
collection suit.
And I'd say that my core group was the
theater kids.
I love my friends from drama and um,
it's really fun having a group of
friends where you'll,
you'll be hanging out on the weekend
shooting the Shit and then you'll get to
school and either be falling in love
with each other and making out on stage
or killing each other on stage.
You know,
we just did fiddler on the roof and I
got to marry one of my best friends.
It was really fun.
I'm sure you're familiar.
I am familiar with the lyrics is a
classic so.
Alright.
So it sounds like a pretty normal
childhood that so far
I don't think someone like me can be
created by normal childhood,
but it was a great childhood.
I'm very happy.
My parents divorced when I was 10 and
I'm lucky enough to have four
grandparents,
parents,
you know,
I've got two brothers and a step sister.
It's a great group.
I'd like to think that I'm a pretty
moral guy and when I'm the shittiest
person in a family,
it's a great family.
So,
um,
you have a standup comic in you.
I can see it.
Hopefully it doesn't come out anytime
soon.
Alright.
So now bring me to that day or earlier
this year.
So on February 14th there was a,
it was a regular day.
It was actually a really nice day and
there was a period of time during the
day that I always remember where I
thought that he's gone a little too.
Well,
I was sitting reading John Walsh's book,
a tears of rage,
I believe,
if you're familiar.
I don't remember the title exactly,
but I was a big fan and um,
I was planning out a Valentine's Day
gift for a girl that I really liked.
Uh,
she had,
uh,
she had an endoscopy that day and she
was,
she was on a lot of medicine and I was
going to give her cousin some gifts for
her and have her bring it to her.
And I made her a card that said I would
have brought you this myself,
but I didn't have the stomach
or Andra.
I printed a picture or a picture of her
doctor
and put it in the cart and everything.
And then I'm were in rehearsal for a
musical we were doing,
he'll vikings,
which I'm sure nobody's ever heard of.
I don't know it.
And uh,
I was,
we had just finished up a song I was
doing and I realized,
wait a second,
I have to go pick up my brother because
that's stillman Douglas School lets out
at 2:40,
but the special needs kids are out at
2:10
so the parents can pick them up before
the buses come and my little brother has
autism and he's hanging out there with
all of his friends and the ESC class.
And by the way,
the autistic scene,
stoneman Douglas is awesome.
Those kids are the best.
And the school specialized in that.
Is it like a magnet school for kids with
autism or.
No,
but it has,
it has a great program with great
teachers.
And I actually went back to Portland
this weekend to see them off to
homecoming.
And boy,
let me tell you,
that squad is wild of them.
And um,
my little brother,
I don't want to brag is kind of the
ringleader over there.
Um,
and,
and I went to go pick them up because on
days like that when my mom was at work,
I would take him to drama and he would
just hang out and he really loved it
because all the girls would give them
attention and you know,
he's,
he's a bit of a cocky little bastard and
I'm a and I realized that it's maybe to
20,
let's say,
and we're halfway through the song and I
say I forgot to pick up holding.
So we finished the song and I asked my
teacher if I could go run and pick them
up.
Of course she said yes,
and I'm picking up holding and suddenly
there's a fire alarm.
And that was a little scary because we
were close to pickup and I was with the
special needs kids.
Some of them were in wheelchairs,
some of whom were not,
were a little physically disabled.
And we had to go to the parking lot
where the buses would come.
And I said,
oh no,
what if this,
what if this is a real fire?
And I have to sit out here and make sure
that nobody gets hit by a bus.
There were teachers there of course,
but you know,
it's a public school.
There maybe two teachers for 10,
15 students who will need a lot of help.
Sure.
So we're out there sitting in the
parking lot and there were students out
there from other classes nearby who,
uh,
because again,
this is a fire drill.
There were students out there who were
with us and it was the Ese class,
it was a couple of the nearby classes.
And one of the kids jokingly said,
as a shooter,
I said,
Dude,
shut the fuck up.
That's not cool because how could that
ever happen?
Right?
And suddenly I see everybody running
back inside and the teacher says,
get inside,
get inside.
And I said,
okay,
it wasn't a real fire.
And they want to get all the kids inside
before the buses come.
And then we're told to go in a room and
we're told to hide,
get away from the window and turn the
lights off.
And I say,
okay,
someone's going on.
And that experience was,
was an interesting one because I was in
the leadership room with a lot of the
leadership students,
which is a class that specializes in
leadership and they planned prom and
everything,
sort of student government and it was
also the special needs kids because it
was the nearest room and some of the
students being nonverbal does not mean
you can't make noise and some of the
students were yelling and wailing.
Unfortunately they had shadows and the
special needs teachers at Douglas are
fantastic and we're able to keep
everybody calm,
but we didn't know what was going on.
And we were there for a couple hours and
slowly more details began to emerge.
I assume you're hearing gunfire and.
No,
no.
Douglas is a huge school and I wasn't.
Now mind you,
I thought I heard gunfire,
but when you're being told you're school
is getting shot up and you hear
anything,
you might think it's gunfire.
But I'm sitting there holding.
My little brother has no idea what's
going on.
And.
And slowly I realized,
okay,
there's a shooting I heard and people
were whispering around the room.
It was maybe 20 kids in the room,
people saying 50 people are dead,
two people are dead.
One person,
his dad.
There were conflicting stories.
I heard conflicting stories of who was
who the shooter was.
I heard five different names.
Wonderful of it was somebody I knew.
Somebody I knew would not pick up a
weapon to harm a butterfly because
that's hysteria and that and that's
natural and I understand it.
Then I saw something that was a terrible
exhibit of humanity.
If you asked me which was.
There was a snapchat video going around
that was that with the caption Yo with
multiple owes my school getting shot up
and it was a video of a dead teacher.
Look,
if you're gonna film shooting from
inside a room so you can have evidence
to show the police good on you.
If you're going to fill my shooting in a
room and say,
Yo my school getting shot up and send it
to everybody,
you know,
that's pretty awful.
And when you're sitting there in a room
not knowing what's going on and you see
videos of people you know and love
deceased.
In the end,
the only video I saw was with somebody
who had,
I had cared about for many years.
He was a mentor in my life.
You start to realize that nothing is
ever going to be the same again.
Yeah.
So
wait,
let's pause for one sec because that we
shouldn't gloss over that part where the
social media component of this is so
important because you guys all grew up
on this and then you grow up hearing
about school shootings all the time.
And I could,
I don't know who this kid is.
It doesn't matter.
I'm sure I'm curious.
Perfectly fine person or he or she even
know what it's like,
you know,
doing that.
It's like,
it just,
it almost feels like,
oh,
that's the normal thing to do.
Like there's a shooting like on
snapchat,
you know,
several people I knew were just treating
it like it was normal.
I mean not the shooting,
but the fact that there was a video and
so I understand how some people might
like to not like,
but you know,
understand having to see that because
they need to understand what's going on.
But I saw it and I said,
how could you do that?
This is somebody who is deceased and
you're filming them to show,
just send it to all your friends and
that's a reflection of the social media
era we're in where everything that's
going on.
You got to show everyone.
So for how long were you actually in
that room?
Not knowing if you were going to be
okay,
not knowing what was happening.
I think it was about two hours.
I could look at interviews I did a days
after and have a much better gauge,
I forget,
but I would call it around two hours.
And you know the.
When the swat team broke the door,
there was the big issue that there are
students who are developmentally
disabled in here who might not be able
to put their hands up.
And fortunately one of the only good
things you'll see from broward handling
of the shooting was the swat team was
very understanding and was very quick to
help these students,
which was good.
But when that glass broke and the first
thing that walked into a room was a,
was a rifle.
How are we supposed to know that that
wasn't us taken our turn,
but and I,
everybody was texting their parents.
Everybody at the phone lines were kind
of jammed because everybody in Parkland
was making a call.
I mean it was Parkland.
It was a city with.
I don't even know how many people,
but it was a small town where there's
one high school.
Is there one high school?
It was around one high school and we.
I mean nobody should be equipped for
this,
but we weren't.
Yeah.
Have you guys been taught at all?
Like are they teaching in high school?
Like what to do if this actually does
happen.
If a shooter,
she comes to school and we had the
discussion of having a code red drill.
We had long discussions about dealing
with a shooter,
but we had never participated in code
red drill,
at least not while I was at school.
I used to skip school a lot.
Tell me a little bit more about the
makeup of Parkland because you mentioned
something interesting that it's kind of
like a little liberal,
pretty liberal area.
It's not homogeneous when it comes to
being liberal,
you know,
there's a lot of different perspectives,
but the majority of people in Parkland
are pretty liberal and pretty classic
liberal and um,
and that's why you'll see a lot of the
activism to come out of snowmen.
Douglas was less,
you know,
let's,
I dunno,
it was very gun control related.
Yeah.
So let's,
we'll,
we'll get to that in a little bit
because obviously so much has happened
in the spotlight that has been put on
you guys and everything else and,
and several of you have stepped into it
and I think there's probably a good part
of that and bad parts of that.
I think that's probably why you were
here right now.
Double Edge Sword.
Um,
okay.
So it ends now what you,
they tell you.
All right.
You could walk out of this room,
I mean,
sure,
I can't imagine that.
So we ran,
we ran with our hands up,
we sat outside for a bit.
Um,
I was able to go on a city bus with my
little brother's class to the Marriott,
which is the hotel only hotel.
And Parkland,
and so they weren't letting parents come
no to the parents were coming to pick us
up at the hotel,
but there were a lot of different ways
students got out of the school,
a lot of different places.
They went,
some kids I know just ran,
which was understandable.
Normally when there's a mass shooting
nearby you run.
And um,
my brother and I were at the Marriott
Hotel and our father picked us up,
took us over an hour to get home
because,
as I'm sure you can understand,
the streets were very jammed.
I mean,
after the shooting,
Parkland was a no man's land.
It,
this wasn't mad max and arche where
everybody was wearing leather spikes,
but it was a no man's land.
There was,
it was as if time and space had been
suspended.
The rules of physics and matter didn't
really exist.
It was eerie.
It was seven days,
at least for me.
That was when that period of really
surreal fear with existed that nothing
felt real.
And,
um,
the news was there,
there was the most we got was somebody
at the sunset and we'll talking about
our production of fiddler on the roof,
the,
um,
did you in that period?
And I'm sure it's very hard to even
remember it clearly.
Did you have a real chance to mourn,
to figure out what happened?
Um,
I don't know.
You can maybe let me know how close you
were to maybe some of the students
because it seems like,
and I think this was part of the problem
with the way we deal with these things
is that we go from the incident to
immediately,
especially on social media,
just attacking each other and destroying
each other.
Then you guys all get thrust into the
spotlight and it's like,
Whoa,
this would be hard on,
on an adult,
you know,
impossibly hard.
Meanwhile you have these kids who are
now out there talking about these
things.
These kids need to mourn.
We need to figure out what's going on
with life and find some reality and
decency.
So I,
I think that there's really no formula
for recovering for from a mass shooting,
especially when at a school,
I mean enough of happened that they're
starting to develop a precedence,
which is a horrible thing,
but there's really nowhere to look.
You can,
I could have hidden away.
I could have locked myself in my room
for weeks and maybe that would have been
the right thing to do.
I could have.
I didn't know what to do and my way of
coping has always been doing something.
I had dealt with some tragic loss this
past year and I had the.
There were some really dark things that
happen to people that I loved and the
way I always handled them was by doing
something.
I never liked to have a clear head
because while I think it's important to
process your pain and deal with it,
I also think that the.
If I,
if something like that happens and I do
nothing,
I'm never going to forget myself.
I had survivor guilt.
Why?
Why should I have left that day?
There were 15 year old girls that were
murdered and I made it out and if I
could have pressed a button to trade my
life for theirs,
it,
it wouldn't have even been.
Hm.
Well,
maybe I should say goodbye to people.
Maybe I should think about this.
No,
I would have broken my finger pressing
it to heart.
So what made me deserve life when other
people who did nothing wrong it people
more innocent,
more kind than I am.
Didn't get to make it out.
And I realized while I'm alive and,
and one of my mentors wasn't Scott
Eagle,
one of the nicest guys I've ever met.
He's the reason that I'm a snarky little
asshole.
I develop that from him.
Um,
he didn't make it out there and he's
somebody who changed the young people's
lives by making them better and making
them more proud of themselves.
So,
so what makes me as what has me
deserving of this.
I'm not a very religious or spiritual
person.
So I,
I don't,
I didn't think there was some great plan
that got me out of school,
but I think that I had a responsibility
at a responsibility to do right by the
people we lost and to do what I thought
would make the world a better place
while they can't,
because there were marriages that didn't
happen.
There were people who would have had
children and didn't get a,
I don't know,
it's a horrible thing to think.
But at the end of the day lives ended
and I still had mine.
So I said after the shooting,
what I'm going to do is something.
And I was uh,
you know,
I've been a big liberal most of my life
and I,
and I've always been an advocate for gun
control.
I was a big debater of other students
after the shooting in Las Vegas where I
said nobody needs.
These were wearing a point in our
society where we're advanced enough that
nobody needs an assault weapon to take
care of themselves.
Look at the,
look at the way these guns are made.
We can defend ourselves in hand.
Guns.
My father has multiple in the house.
He's a reserve police officer.
He was Miami shores for awhile.
I didn't.
I instantly said the thing we can do
here,
stop folks like the shooter at my school
from getting these weapons because this
is a 19 year old who if he had spent
five minutes with the psychologist would
have been sent to a therapist,
not a gun store.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's.
Before we get specifically to far down
the road here,
which obviously we're going to touch on.
Okay.
You guys are trying to more and you
know,
you're having survivor guilt.
All of these things I'm sure just in,
in your family and your brother and
everything else.
Just I can't even imagine then the media
because I think this is,
we have to hit media stuff before we get
to the gun part.
The media then descend.
What was that like?
I mean,
I assume everybody and their brother was
trying to reach out to all of you guys.
They were putting you guys on TV.
I mean,
I probably even that very day.
Um,
what was that like for you guys
or for you?
Uh,
you know,
the whole,
our whole situation with the media,
whether it be anything from CNN to Fox
News to Ellen was a double edge sword
because on the one,
on the one hand there are bodies that
are warm and right here on TV and in
retrospect I might have done that
differently.
I'm not sure.
On the other hand,
I couldn't let this be like Sandy Hook
for example.
They couldn't let this be people coming
in to film crying,
mothers talking about how bad these guns
are and leave.
I wanted to get out there and say,
no,
okay,
this,
how many of these do we need before we
do something that I don't.
I didn't want people to see Parkland as
a place where everybody was crying and
everybody was throwing a pity party.
I wanted to people to see Parkland as a
place where a terrible tragedy happened
and the city stood up and said,
no,
we're not going to be like these other
places.
We are going to be a catalyst.
I mean,
before before Stoneman Douglas,
I would send.
I would hear the word sandy hook in a
room and everybody would get quiet and
it would be weird.
I couldn't have that be stoneman Douglas
at this place.
That was my school.
I loved my school.
I was a big school spirit fellow.
It was about to become a statistic.
It was about to become that one dark
thing that somebody will make a joke
about or somebody will say something bad
about or really anything.
So I got out there and said no.
And so many people got out there and
said,
this cannot be another example of
everybody.
Everybody crying.
We're not here to cry.
We're here to tell you what we can do to
make this a better world.
Were there people swim,
parents,
advisors,
whoever,
that were kind of guiding you through
the media part of this?
Because there were so many strange
moments where it seemed like,
like I said to you right before,
I don't want to make this about any
specific student especially,
and I don't want to throw anyone out on
the bus,
but when we see someone like David Hogg
who obviously is very public now,
uh,
you know,
saying things that didn't quite seem
right or,
or talking about laws and all this stuff
like going from just surviving to
suddenly advocacy with almost no space
in between,
you know,
in general.
I think the general idea of going right
to advocacy,
while it might not have been our best
call to immediately go to it was these
cameras are only here for so long and we
couldn't have them leave a double edged
sword.
Exactly.
So do we,
do we wait our respectful time and then
go out and advocate or what people not
care.
And I think I stand by advocacy.
I'm not sure.
I think on a moral level I might not but
on a.
But generally,
I think that while everybody was
looking,
we had to say,
let's,
let's look at what we really want to
look at here.
These like give these families.
There's
base were,
were any of you guys afraid that you
were being looked at as experts suddenly
where as horrific as what happened to
you was it doesn't make you an expert
either in law or in guns or any of those
things like you can very eloquently as
you're doing right now.
Tell me your story.
Tell me what you think.
All of those things.
But especially at the beginning,
I'm sure you know way more now.
You don't know everything.
Nobody knows everything.
And they were throwing a bunch of 17
year olds out there as if they were
experts on all of these things.
And I think that also added to some of
the,
the tumbled around everything.
Well at the time it was awesome.
Yeah.
I mean I was an expert.
I,
I felt,
I felt phenomenal.
I was somebody that everybody was
looking to as if I,
as if I knew everything.
And as I said before,
that was what I wanted.
And it wasn't a good feeling.
I,
I'll be honest with you,
some things about it felt good.
Most of it felt like a terrible
interesting.
You just said it's awesome and it wasn't
a good feeling.
That probably sums it up,
I guess.
Yeah,
it was awesome to me that I got to the.
I spent my whole life watching people
talk about laws and watching people talk
about politics and now I got to say this
and my word got to be respected.
But every time I went out there I
thought there are people then.
And it's,
it's just,
it's a,
it's a moral qualm.
Am I out here at,
I'm doing this because I believe in it
and I'm doing this because I don't want
the world to lose people again.
Uh,
yeah.
Nobody deserves to be shot.
Nobody at all.
Nobody who's a good person deserves to
be shot.
So,
so I,
it was,
it was difficult for me because on the
one hand,
it was this amazing feeling of,
here's my voice.
Everybody's listening.
Let me tell you what you all need to
hear.
And what everybody needed to hear was we
need to pass gun laws.
It's been enough.
If,
if,
if people did nothing after columbine,
I would have understood it because that
was supposed to be an anomaly.
I'm sure you remember.
That was a shocker.
And then stoneman Douglas happened and
it was more of an,
another not a woe.
So,
so it felt it.
It felt great that people were carrying.
That was the,
that was what I would say it was the
awesome part was that I was afraid
everybody would.
Everybody in the country would feel
helpless and cry and be done.
But it was amazing to see that the
country was saying maybe there's
something we can do here,
maybe we can make some change.
And the thing that was awful was I was,
I was going from news hits two memorial
services.
Yeah.
So you've had a sort of interesting
evolution about all this and it.
And it sort of leads to where we're
going to end,
which is what you're doing now,
which is pretty awesome.
Um,
so,
all right,
you're part of the.
Now you're part of the media machine.
You guys are trying to figure out what
can you do?
I assume that's sort of how march for
our life started and if I'm not
mistaken,
it started in your house,
right?
Started in my bathroom.
Yeah,
I was,
um,
I was coming out of the shower,
putting on my ghostbusters PJ's.
It was a slimer.
It wasn't old school ghostbusters.
Yes,
of course.
Of course I am.
We can talk about the new ghost busters
maybe after this part.
How much eight do you want to get
online?
I love.
I'll tell you this.
Everybody in that cast is incredibly
talented.
I didn't like the movie very much,
but there's really nobody who is in it
that I think was not in.
It's not an incredibly funny person.
But anyway,
I,
um,
started in my home and,
and I got a lot of my friends together.
Some I called everyone who I knew was
intelligent and well spoken and was
willing to put their time to grieve
aside to demand action because if you
know,
I felt like it was in some ways public
service because people are grieving and
we're out here saying,
we're gonna.
Put that aside as as much as I wanted to
cry every day and mind you,
I really want to do,
and I did a lot.
I knew that I had to put that aside.
I had to do something so I got everybody
that I knew could do something to mostly
my drama friends because I knew that
they could speak and we all got together
at my house and said,
well,
what do we do with this whole,
this whole country?
People on both sides or all morning
together.
How can we get everybody on both sides
together to do something now?
Mind you,
that didn't happen.
Getting people on both sides didn't
really happen.
That can be a tough one and it is a
tough one and then it will always be a
tough one,
but it's something that needs to be
done.
And,
and you know,
from,
from my home,
we were sleeping two hours a night.
I would go entire days only eating one
protein bar,
not even realizing we were.
So it was such a tornado that we were
all,
we all kind of forgot what it was like
to be a normal person.
So you come up with the idea for March
for our lives,
now,
get us to that day.
And what was it supposed to be?
What,
what were the actual original intentions
beyond,
let's not forget about this.
Original intentions were let's get gun
control passed and I'm still a big,
let's get gun control pass guy.
And um,
and that's what we wanted to do.
We want to say everybody out here
saying,
we should do this.
Let's get everyone together.
Let's,
let's get a,
a big march together where people say,
I want.
I'm coming all the way out here.
I'm standing out here today to demand
this.
And seeing everybody together was
amazing.
I,
um,
you get getting up on the stage and
seeing all those people.
I didn't care about the being in front
of him.
I mean,
I was a drama kid,
I stood in front of people and taught
for the past five years,
but I saw all those people and I said,
these people believe in something.
The these people come from different
places.
These people that are all completely
different,
but they're all together because they
believe in one thing and that was
magical and I don't use the word magical
very often.
I think it's Cliche,
but that was magical and it was.
It was.
It was amazing to see.
But from the beginning of our advocate
advocacy to the march,
it was,
it was a lot of personalities together
and we were able to make it through the
pain we felt together.
I mean,
so often people said,
well,
why are you guys at your school got shot
up a month ago?
Your school got shot up three weeks ago.
Why are you smiling?
And I said,
well,
at least from my own personal
perspective,
the teacher that I was dear friends
with,
that I lost.
Scott wouldn't want me to cry.
Scott would want me to do something.
Scott would want me to do what I
believed in.
He wasn't a very political guy.
He will,
after the shooting,
he probably wouldn't have focused on any
politics.
He would have focused on getting
everybody at Douglas to feel better,
to laugh,
to smile.
But if I believed in something and I
wanted to advocate for it,
I knew that if he were here,
he'd say,
well,
go do it.
So the time I spent,
I was sitting at his memorial and I was
crying and my,
I was,
it was in the dirt.
I was all snotty.
I,
I tried to wipe my face and my dirty
hands and I,
it was what many would consider the low
point in a movie when the person feels
like they've lost everything.
And then I thought about it and if Scott
Yoda to behind me as a ghost,
which he and I used to talk about.
Actually,
I used to talk about Yoda Ang,
if he yoda behind me and he would say,
Cameron,
do something.
You must.
He used to talk to me in Yoda voice a
lot and not go.
We were going to get your Yoda
impression there and it's not gonna
happen.
Um,
somebody else has the exclusive on that
one?
No,
there were points where Scott was my
teacher in fifth grade.
He Yoda voice to me while I was asking
him a genuine question,
which frustrated me a lot,
but it's time.
I could do a three hour interview on
him,
but he would said do something.
So,
so when we were all smiling together,
when we were all laughing together,
it was because I knew that somebody that
I love would have wanted me to and we
had each other.
That's the thing.
If I were,
if I was advocating for gun control
alone,
it wouldn't have worked.
Not only because I couldn't have done it
alone.
I'm not good enough to do it alone,
but also because we were each other's
lifeline when I was,
when,
when everything seemed awful and
everything seemed like the world was
this dark,
terrible place.
I had my friends around me to say,
we were here for you.
We've got this together.
And I was,
you know,
some people's shoulder.
Many people were in my shoulder.
I'm more emotional than many.
I'm a theater student.
So more people had to help me that I
need to help them and feel beyond the
emotional part and getting everybody
together.
And as you said,
you're still a gun control advocate and
all that.
I sent that part of what happened around
March for our labs was you saw things
getting bizarrely political or or more
than perhaps you were.
You guys wanted.
Is that fair to say?
I think what march for our lives should
have.
See it's a political issue.
I think the way it should have come off,
and I think this is what everybody I
worked with believes.
I know that for a fact is that kids
don't want to get shot.
That's what we are at the end of the
day.
We are kids who are out here saying we
don't want to die.
And back then I thought that if you
didn't believe in gun control beliefs,
you didn't care if kids died.
I learned that that's not the case,
but that's a pretty interesting
evolution for someone at 17 to have with
him.
You know,
five or six months I spoke to people who
disagree with me.
I learned that they want the country to
be a better place,
you know,
that they might not agree on how we
might think.
I might think that their views are horse
shit,
but every.
We all agree on basically 90 percent of
things and I'm sure there are plenty of
political things you and I will disagree
on,
but at the end of the day,
Tom Mcfarland is one of the most gifted
spiderman writers to agree on that.
Do you ever do anything with DC?
I'm more of a marvel guy,
but I had a pretty good Batman
collection for awhile.
Nightwing is my favorite superhero,
if you're familiar.
I think.
I think in comic books they're very
afraid to make real change and nightwing
actually was able to make it through
that.
You know,
if,
uh,
if a robin became his own superhero,
normally that would only be for 10
issues and then he'd go back.
But night we actually made that jump.
I encourage you all to read.
Going back,
we can focus on Mcfarlane Spiderman from
to 98 to 3:35.
That the idea of venom is brilliant,
but I saw the movie trailer for the
movie.
We'll talk about that off camera.
Um,
sounds good.
Tom Hardy's gifted.
So,
so the way,
the way people should have seen us in
the way I failed really in the messaging
because I was so deeply involved with it
was we just don't want to get killed and
quickly because of the perfect storm of
everything it became left versus right.
And,
and I don't think anybody in my group
wanted that.
I don't think anybody in my group wants
that at all.
But it's in one way the media is the
media's portrayal.
It's in one way my personal inability to
express it correctly and another way,
my arrogance,
because I was pretty arrogant.
I mean that from the bottom of my heart.
I mean everybody else I worked with a
march for our lives was a,
a kid who wanted to help the world,
but I was a cocky little son of a bitch
and that,
and that translated a lot because I said
I'm right.
That's the thing.
Everything I say about gun control is
completely right.
So,
so why?
Why don't,
why aren't you listening to me?
Because I'm obviously in the right here
and everybody else again was,
was basically saying I don't want to
die.
Here's how I think it could work.
But I said,
I'm right politically.
This is my political movement.
Listened to my politics.
That's my fault.
And that's okay.
I'm playing myself.
I was a kid who lost friends and I
thought that this is what we needed and
I still do,
but my,
my big error,
my what?
What's the,
what's the word from a tragic hero?
That's their flaw.
Hamartia.
Hubris.
Well,
this is your Hubris,
I suppose.
Let's call it the Hubris.
I again,
I didn't take ap Lang or ap lit.
I can tell you my favorite tragic
heroes.
I love tragic heroes,
but my hubris was an.
Again,
I could be interpreting this wrong.
I just thought I was right.
I thought that anybody who didn't agree
with me because I was so right,
wanted kids to die one percent of the.
No,
I wouldn't say that.
My guess is that three percent of the
country doesn't care when kids die three
percent.
Just as not my kid or you know,
it's not where I am,
but the rest of the country doesn't want
kids to die.
And you know,
I learned about that,
that family in Texas where the mom and
the dad both carry weapons because they
wanna protect their family.
I learned about the people in,
in everywhere who want to protect their
families.
I have guns in my house and while I
believe in an assault weapons ban,
or at least much more restrictive laws,
if you want to hurt my autistic brother
and I have a gun,
you're in trouble.
So when you see
someone like David Hogg,
and I'm only mentioning him because he's
been so vocal on,
uh,
you know,
I try to talk about ideas and not
people,
but when you see someone like him
tweeting all of these things,
but you know,
I don't want to get an exact quote
crossed up here,
but to the effect,
if you don't agree with me,
you want dead kids.
Republicans want dead kids.
Marco Rubio doesn't want to save
anybody.
All of these things,
you now realize that's just not the way
to do it.
That is not true and it's not.
It's not actually effective.
The reason I criticize myself and not my
friends,
because I know David,
David is a dear friend of mine.
I've known him for a couple of years,
but I've only known him really well
since the shooting.
I had a class with him once.
He was nice guy.
Everything David does,
and I know we're not talking specifics,
but I'll just use David as an example
because much like everybody else in
March for our lives,
everything David does,
he does because he wants the country to
be a better place.
He and I don't always see perfectly Idi
on what exactly to do,
but every time I something he tweets
that I don't like and I looked,
I think about it and I say,
I've spent hours with David.
I've known him.
I know him so incredibly well because we
have this dark,
tragic,
terrible bond that was really created
after the worst case scenario.
But when David says something that I
don't agree with you saying it because
he doesn't want another kid to die.
So you know,
messaging with everybody in the group is
occasionally not really in sync.
We agree.
We disagree on things sometimes,
but if I thought that people in March
for our lives like David or anyone was
in this for the wrong reasons,
I would be instant.
I would instantly call them out.
I don't think that's the case.
Yeah.
Unfortunately the road to hell is paved
with good intentions and I don't want
to.
SMIRCH has intentions.
It was fine.
I believe you.
I believe you that his intentions are
pure.
I of course,
I believe that
David's a guy who cares so deeply about
the world around him and we'll do
whatever it takes to make it a better
place.
But it's funny that you say the road to
hell is paved with good intentions
because our summer tour where we went
around advocating for more voter
registration and more accessible voting
around the country was called road to
change.
And there was a counter protester I one
of our events that said more like the
road to hell.
I said,
hey,
that's not very nice.
Okay.
So after the march,
during the march,
before the march,
this thing is just becoming more and
more political.
As you said.
You guys are getting up there and you
want to,
you know,
sort of have your moment.
But there are certain issues you don't
understand.
We're politicians reaching out to you.
Uh,
I know that,
you know,
Kyle [inaudible] shoe of his talk to
Marco Rubio a couple of times.
I mean,
how,
how deep did this go in terms of
reaching every part of American society?
Sure.
We,
um,
we reached out to a lot of people and a
lot of people reached out to us.
There were a lot of conservatives that
we,
we were speaking to about the issue.
I have a couple friends who went to gun
groups to talk about it,
sat down with some very big gun
advocates in their areas,
not really in the country but notable
where they were to talk about the issue
and I know that the rest of my group was
really interested in opening up and
talking about this.
Again.
I was the shitty one in March for our
lives.
I wanted to stir some shit.
You know,
I wanted to cause trouble.
I wanted to make,
I wanted to own the conservatives the
same way a lot of conservatives want to
own the libs.
I mean that's what it's about right now.
People,
people play games where they're trying
to one up each other and you know,
I just,
I was trying to do that.
I was trying to make politicians.
I didn't like look bad as opposed to
say,
what can we do when I went up there
and I was where your folks or anyone
saying,
you know,
maybe ease up on twitter or like,
just just because you're going to get no
matter what,
even if everything you said was
factually right and came from the right
place and all that,
just the amount of hate you're going to
get while you're still a young person in
the morning.
So it cannot be fun.
My mom is her sole existence in the
world is to make everybody in the world
happy and love each other.
So she said to me,
be nice and loving.
My Dad,
who is a bit of a political advocate
himself,
agrees with me on a lot of things and
sometimes he would tell me to ease up.
Sometimes he would tell me to,
you know,
be be a little bit rougher.
But he also said,
and this is why I think my parenting
from my mom,
Stepdad,
dad step mom was so great,
was they said,
do what you think is right and don't let
people put their hooks in you.
And I did.
I let I let I let people manipulate me a
bid because I,
I thought that they were kindred
spirits.
But you know,
my parents,
I'm lucky enough to have parents who
say,
believe what you believe if my,
you know,
my parents are all liberal.
But if I came home and said,
I'm,
if I came home with a trump 20 slash 20,
which I do not expect to do unless some
drastic change happens in my life.
Although I know you're not thrilled with
the Democrats with moment.
Come on,
throw the Democrats at the moment.
But I'm not thrilled with Democrats at
the moment because they're not being
good Democrats.
Not because they're Democrats.
But we'll get to that.
I,
um,
if I came home and I told my parents
that I would vote for the opposite of
what they would vote for,
they would say if you're doing it
because you think it's right,
you're going to do it.
And I'm very grateful for that.
So we're.
Do you stand on gun control?
Generally?
Because I think what happened was they
at the event at March for our lives,
there were a lot of people getting up
there and they were saying things that
implied,
and I think this is the way a lot of
people on the right took it.
It's not about sensible gun control.
This is ultimately about taking away all
the guns.
And that of course is the fear of most
of the people on the right.
And there were a couple of the students,
there was one young girl,
I don't remember who said we're going to
start with bump stocks,
but we're coming for all the guns or
something to that effect.
And that that feeds right into the
people on the right who go,
all right,
well now we're not going to talk you
guys to negotiate who like better law as
you guys are Mao Zedong.
Exactly.
And then because of that,
then the people on the left and you guys
go,
well,
right now they don't want to talk at
all,
so we're not going to talk.
And then you end up sort of exactly
where we're at at the moment.
It's an.
This is.
Somebody told me this the other day.
It's a brilliant point.
The left and the right attack each
other's worst arguments and that does
nothing for us.
But when it comes to my personal stance
on guns,
there's some.
There are some differing opinions
amongst my friends from our for our
lives,
but we all,
we all agree with some similar things.
Personally,
I think that as long as people who are
responsible can carry concealed
firearms,
particularly handguns in the country,
in many situations,
the country is a safer place.
I also think that there is not a strong
vetting process for people to purchase
these firearms and a lot of people just
get guns and a lot of these people are
not the good guy with the gun because I
think the good guy with a gun argument
is just a hasty generalization.
I understand it in some ways because I
intend to concealed carry when I'm an
adult because I intended to have a
family and I intend to shoot anybody who
tries to kill my family and I assumed
that that even that position right there
probably puts you on the outs with a lot
of,
a lot of your crew.
Conceptually,
you know,
we respect each other's opinions.
So if somebody in March for our lives,
and this is nobody in our lives,
but if somebody said,
I want to eliminate all guns,
I'd say,
okay,
well let's talk about that.
So you know,
my friends respect me for what I think
and I respect them some.
It's difficult.
It's a difficult thing to respect people
who disagree with you for those things.
So you find that,
you know guys and girls your age are
able to have these conversations without
killing each other.
There was a terrible choice of words
without sure,
without being at each other's throats.
I think more than adults are right now.
Is that possible because that seems to
be a through line with you that you're
friends with.
A lot of people have different opinions.
I think we want to.
I think that a lot of people who want to
orange taking the right steps because
they're saying yes we can.
We can come to some common ground if you
agree with me and there's a,
there's a want out there and that's
something I'm really interested in
because I come from a generation that I
believe puts principles and morals over
money and political victories and I
think that we've actually got a bright
future now.
People will call me in insane.
Bobby Kennedy more for saying that we
have a bright future,
but I think we do.
I think we need to de stigmatize the
conversation.
I had a lot of friends who who before
seven months ago I would have thought
were racist,
sexist,
bigoted,
homophobes who want the country to
explode and want to destroy everybody
who isn't exactly like them,
and then I learned maybe that's not the
case and I have a lot of friends who
would have thought that I was some
leftist,
Beta Kuk shill who who wanted,
who wanted the communists to take
everybody's guns and kill them,
and then they learn.
Maybe that's not the case.
I think our generation really is moving
in a good direction when it comes to
smart conversations.
I just think we need a bit of a social
revolution.
They're not a huge social revolution.
I love social revolutions.
This isn't a big revolutions.
Cool.
At Beatles,
la,
ms dot level,
yet we're not.
We're not hearing that people sing the
song and making me men yet,
but we there.
We need some.
We need a.
We need a,
a movement towards respecting each other
because look,
before all of this,
if I could have gotten rid of the right,
I would have,
and I know people who would have gotten
rid of the left if they could have,
but it's not going to happen.
The parties might evolve over time.
I mean,
the parties or the parties are flipping
in a lot of ways.
Think about this.
The party of Lincoln is the only party
that currently we're not the Democrats.
There are some Democrats who are like
this,
but the majority of people who are
running as admitted white supremacists
are part of the party of Lincoln.
So a Lotta,
a Lotta switches happen there.
Um,
I mean,
you've got some really awful rhetoric
out there from folks like Candice Owens
who will say,
we will talk about the left plantation.
Look,
I think identity politics are dangerous,
but calling saying that the real racists
or the Democrats is a hasty
generalization,
I think.
I think there's actually some truth to
it.
There's a difference between the
liberals and the left.
Now you're speaking my language.
The thing is you can't pigeon hole them
together.
Aspirational the right word for that.
Yeah.
Okay.
You can't pigeonhole them together.
I'm a liberal,
but I think that all men and women are
created equal and need to be respected
equally.
Whereas people farther to the left will
say,
as a,
as a white,
cisgender,
heterosexual male,
I don't have the right to say any of
that.
Look you.
A friend of mine,
Michael Skolnik,
who I've worked with before,
said something to me that I really
appreciated,
which was you can't judge somebody by
the hand they're dealt.
You judge them by how they elect to play
that hand.
People farther to the left will judge me
by the hand I'm dealt.
I grew up in a pretty well off family.
I had a pretty easy childhood.
I could've walked around my neighborhood
without fearing death,
which is something that some of my
friends I made in Chicago,
we're not able to have,
but they'll say that my opinion is less
valid than anybody's because I don't
deal with the struggles they do.
I have an incredible amount of empathy
for people who are not as privileged as
I am.
I believe that white privilege exists.
I don't believe it's as systematic or,
or,
um,
really structural as people say it is.
I don't think the government exists to
oppressed people,
but white privilege I believe exists.
I believe that there are certain
situations where I will be,
where I will be in a better place
because I'm a white cisgender
heterosexual male.
Again,
it's not this large oppressive force
that people treat it like,
but it's something we need to address
and that's it.
That's the real thing I'm talking about
recently,
which is we can find common ground on
these issues and not try to push each
other away because in my view,
in my view,
white privilege exists and people will
say,
well no,
because in many situations on the sat,
African American students were given
points and Asian students were,
were deducted points.
And,
and that proves that,
that,
well,
I got myself into,
yeah,
well I don't want.
We don't have to go too far down down
that road because we could have a whole
other conversation on that because I,
I,
I actually don't agree with you on that,
but,
but that's the point of this.
That's the point.
And I'm still learning.
You're still learning it.
It's kind of a beautiful thing.
Yeah.
I'm 17.
I can hardly smell.
I'm not the expert on Shit.
And that's actually the point of the new
podcast I'm putting out pretty soon.
It's called Cameron knows nothing.
Uh,
do you watch game of thrones?
I do.
Look at Grit.
Told me,
and it's true,
you know,
I had my own personal views on abortion.
I actually,
I watched a video of yours where you and
I have this pretty much the same exact
view on the 20 weeks guy.
Um,
but I also have not taken enough science
classes.
I also do not have not conversed with
enough women who have had abortions.
My opinions mean Jack Shit to have them,
you know,
it's just,
I'm a 17 year old boy,
so there's only so much I can truly say
about pro lifers pro choice,
but I'm allowed to say it.
Yeah.
And you know,
in Cameron knows nothing.
I'm to tell you guys what I think
but doesn't mean it's right.
Where do you think that attitude comes
from within you?
Because it seems to me that I think a
lot of what's happening right now is I
see adults that are now afraid to say
what they think and you know,
they think that the mob is going to come
after them,
which is completely legit.
They think it might hurt.
There are job opportunities or things
like that.
Yeah,
the mob,
whichever,
whichever way it is.
Right.
I mean,
I think what we see boycotts on both
sides and I think a lot of misguided
anger off and uh,
but I think most people need a little
bit more of what you just did there,
which is I just am what I am,
you know,
maybe convinced me as some other stuff,
but I'm trying to learn here.
I don't want to hurt anybody,
you know,
I,
I don't,
I want the government to crack down on
guns.
That doesn't mean I want the government
to oppress you.
Uh,
I believe that there's a certain amount
of time somebody should have access to
an abortion and I think that abortion
should be more accessible just for a
certain amount of time,
but I don't want to kill babies and I
don't want to oppress women.
I want the world to be a better place.
You want the world to be a better place.
Um,
I don't know about,
about,
you know,
anybody up in the booth,
but they seem really nice.
They're pretty good.
Todd Macfarlane,
I hand selected these people.
Exactly.
Todd Mcfarlane wants the world to be a
better place.
David Hogg wants the world to be a
Uh,
Jordan Peterson wants the world.
We all pretty much all of us.
Do I,
I'm actually glad you mentioned Jordan
Peterson because you know,
I'm on tour with him right now.
And one of the things that I find is
first,
if I meet a ton of people your age,
I'd say the bulk of the people that are
coming there are young people probably
probably right around your age,
17,
18 into,
into their probably early thirties and
it's male,
female,
gay,
straight,
black,
white,
the whole thing.
But it's very obvious to me that he's
providing some level of guidance that
somehow it seems that your generation
kind of missed.
Now it sounds like your,
your folks are pretty great and your
extended family and all that.
But do you sense that there is some
missing piece here that partly.
I don't know that there's some.
I,
I discussed this last week with Peter
Teal,
that there was some disconnect between
the baby boomers,
my parents age and that,
that my guys,
the gen x people,
we never had our moment or something.
And then we've sort of handed it off to
you guys,
the millennials and Gen x,
Gen z actually.
Wow.
When did those are?
Three or four years older than I am.
Alright man,
we're all in trouble.
I don't want to feel bad that we handed
it off to the,
to the generation of people who grew up
with cell phones,
immediate access to knowledge.
We are the best and worst thing to ever
happen to us.
If I wanted to get to a hospital,
I can get to a hospital much easier with
the cell phone if I want to look up a
fact,
forgetting the fact that facts are
difficult right now because it's a fact
that facts are difficult to find.
Guide is if,
um,
you know,
I can do it,
but also I,
I've,
before all of this,
I was very,
very obsessed with my own image,
not because I thought I had a good one,
but because I wanted it to be good.
I was posting things online because I
wanted people to think I had a cool
life.
I mean,
I did.
I had a great life,
but I want people to know that.
And,
and it,
it the
hyperconnectivity of social media,
which is a term I stole from many Ben
Platt interviews where he's talking
about his musical.
Do you Evan Hansen?
I don't want him to see this and think
I'm stealing the hyperconnectivity of
social media is,
um,
is,
is a good and bad thing.
But I think the problem here,
and I think that,
you know,
folks like Jordan,
I'm a big fan of Jordan.
I'm a big fan of yours.
Don't get a big head of people.
People like you guys.
One of the things that you advocate for
his,
his conversation and people on the right
young people on the right that I know
and I'm friends with,
they want to own the lips.
This is all about proving them wrong and
saying like,
facts don't care about your feelings.
I agree.
Facts by definition don't care about
your feelings,
but there's also logic which is kind of
the middle between the two really.
And that's the interpretation and the
insight and the fact where we,
if we,
if we only based everything in fact,
which a lot of young people have the
right to,
we're just talking about the past.
You can't look at the future and you can
assess facts,
but a lot of a lot of young people on
the right one to prove people wrong and
a lot of young people on the left,
I've seen wants to want to make,
want to make people who disagree with
them look worse.
It's all about making the other look
worse,
the right ones to show that the left is
a bunch of copies and left wants to show
that the rights of bunch of fascists and
that's a waste of time.
That is a.
That is what is harming our country
right now.
I think Donald Trump's rhetoric is
dangerous and harms our country,
but trump is is the is a symptom of
something greater like President Obama
said when he made his return,
the made all of my liberal friends think
Jesus came back,
which is,
you know,
trump.
Trump is the result of a country where
the people who love trump are loving him
more than ever in the people who hate
trump.
I hated it more than ever because we're
divided.
You know our rhetoric is,
is driving,
is driving everybody in different
directions.
That's why you see the rise of
democratic socialism and that's why you
see the rise of more and more people
coming out and saying things that are
stupid because they have the first man
right to do it.
Look,
if you say something I don't like,
I will defend it with my life.
I will defend with my life.
You're right to say it,
but people are mixing,
being not pc and being a jerk and and
right now we're driving apart.
We need to come together,
stop attacking each other.
Both sides are equally as guilty in
certain sides in certain situations are
obviously guilty gear,
but it,
it's,
it's bullshit.
So do you sense a little more
flexibility on the ability to talk to
people on the right than on the left
because you know that that's been a sort
of
a big part of what's going on with me.
Like I get invited to go to these
conservative things and turning point
USA and I talk about being gay married
and I'm pro choice and against the death
penalty and all of these things that are
thought of as leftists things,
but they invite me.
We have a great time.
I take a zillion selfies with the kids
after and all that stuff where there
doesn't seem to be that flexibility over
there.
And now I get,
I don't want to harp on this because I
get your greater point,
which is we got to get past this.
What I am,
I do see something on one side,
especially young people that
has become more corroded,
I would say.
Then,
uh,
then on the other side,
here's what I'll say.
I'll say the left cares too much about
people in the right doesn't care enough.
And I'll tell you what I mean,
because they're,
they're equally as wrong.
Here.
The young people on the right will
attack you with facts in,
in,
in either positive or negative ways.
And they're open to conversation very
often I believe because they want to
prove you wrong.
That's what I've seen from that.
That's not a fact.
It's an opinion.
Whereas people on the left wants to
accommodate for everybody so much that
if you say anything negative about
anybody that they agree with,
they jumped to their defense.
So I'll bring up the Israel argument,
which is an argument that I don't know
enough about to form an opinion.
I truly do not,
but if you are a pro palette,
that sounds like pretty much everybody.
Exactly.
Being pro Palestine doesn't mean you
hate the Jews necessarily,
and being pro Israel doesn't mean that
you hate everybody who you hate.
Palestinians,
but I'll talk to people on the right and
they'll.
They'll be happier to talk about it then
people on the left,
but the second I'd say that,
you know,
Palestine should have land,
which again,
I don't,
I don't have a firm opinion on.
They'll say,
dude,
you're Jewish.
How could you say that?
I'll say because people are people and
then I'll talk to people on the left
about it and I'll say,
there's a lot of concerns of tear and
they'll say,
don't you dare call everybody that
everybody who's Palestinian terrorist
and on both sides.
You're so,
so yes.
I think the right is more open to
conversation,
but I think that more people on the
right are trying to lure you into a cave
where they can prove you wrong.
I don't want to be proven right or wrong
right now.
I want to discuss because my opinions on
things have changed.
My opinions really are not taking a one
80.
I have all my opinions,
but my opinion on opinions is changing.
That's that's the most important thing
I'd like to highlight here if I'm
talking.
I used to think that,
and we've talked about this.
I used to think that if you didn't agree
with me,
you hate me.
Now I've learned a different thing and
I'm not,
and what I'm advocating for now is I'm
not asking people to change their
perspectives.
I'm asking people to stop having your
feet so firmly on the ground when you're
a child,
because I'm a child.
You know I can't rent a car.
I can't smoke a cigarette,
nor do I intend to,
but at the end of the day,
I can't tell you about.
I can't tell you with authority about
economics.
I can tell you what I think.
I haven't taken an econ class or finance
class and we need young already doing
better than most experts on CNN.
I think people on the left and the right
need to need to realize that facts are
facts.
Feelings are feelings,
logic,
his logic,
but the more and more we try to prove
each other wrong,
the less progress we're going to make
because I have had the mindset.
That's why I understand it.
I've had the mindset,
we're all I wanted to do is just own the
conservatives and I know people have had
the mindset where all they want to do is
own the lips by.
By the way,
I know you're not.
You're saying this because Kyle
[inaudible] Hsu,
who I've gotten to know well,
who falls off and on the other side of
this
and you,
he's now working with turning point and
he's trying to strengthen the second
amendment and all sorts of other things.
Uh,
you guys are friends and you guys are
still able to talk about these things.
And we had originally said maybe we
could get both you guys in here,
but we thought this would be a good
opportunity just to let you do your
thing and I'll have kyle on separately.
But you guys are,
despite your differences,
you're,
you're able to talk
a lot of things.
Kyle does.
I don't like a lot.
Almost everything he says,
I disagree with some things he says that
I think are inappropriate.
I've said some inappropriate stuff and,
and you know,
I understand if you don't agree with me
and you want to come out and speak,
I,
I'm proud that I was able to speak after
the shooting.
And Kyle did too.
So I haven't.
I have a deep understanding of his
position.
So beyond the podcast,
and I will give you my word that I will
do the podcast.
Oh please.
No,
I was.
Yeah.
Well you asked me to do it.
The email was.
Can you do my phone that I'm lucky
enough to be here?
Yeah.
I'm more than happy to do it.
We'll,
we'll make that happen.
Um,
what,
what do you want to do?
Have you,
have you really been able to think about
it at this point?
I know it's sort of an annoying
question.
Can I ask a young person?
No.
I mean,
you know,
I can't tell you what college I want to
go to.
I can't tell you where I want to be in
50 years,
but I can tell you that right now.
I want to dedicate my time to do them
what I think is the best thing I could
do with my platform because I have a
large platform for all the worst
reasons.
And with great platform comes great
responsibility.
Spiderman.
Exactly.
Uncle Ben said that,
I believe it wasn't a gold band,
but when you say uncle Ben on this show,
people might be like kindly talking
about entropy.
Ben Parker and I have responsibility to
do what I think is right and what I
think is right is advocating for what I
believe in,
but also making sure that the
conversation is mended and healed
because who better than the people who
are about to become adults to try and
make sure that our next generation of
adults knows how to work together.
I mean,
you got Nelson and Rubio in Florida.
I'll give you a great example.
Nelson Rubio had passed some great bills
together because Nelson Rubio don't see
eye to eye,
but they are able to put their
differences aside.
They get along and I want more of that.
Yeah.
Well man,
yeah.
I know a lot of people were worried
about the future,
but I mean it's clear to me that your
future is bright and if we can hand it
over,
we're going to hand it over to to,
to people like you will.
We'll be all right because this is.
This is everything that I've been trying
to do here.
I think it's summed up in the way that
you're trying to go forward with life.
It's pretty awesome.
Really.
It's inspiring.
I appreciate that.
Let me ask you something,
your show.
So I'm going to.
We're going to swap your flip it and you
are in theater.
All right.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
um,
so what,
what are the qualities you're looking
for in a candidate if you are going to
vote for them over president trump in
20,
20.
Oh Man.
You're really putting me on the spot
here.
This is my show.
Look,
I've said this before,
but it seems to me that the,
unfortunately the democratic socialist
wing of the Democrats has gone really
far left.
I mean,
look,
the word socialist is in the,
is in the title now,
and purge,
right?
I guess they're being honest for what
they are and they're fighting for what
they believe in.
I happen to disagree with virtually all
of it,
but that they're doing that.
They've basically purged what I think
are the remaining liberals,
as you said,
classical liberals before.
And I think unfortunately that leaves a
lot of us.
It's why people watch my show because
I've just been honest about what I see
here.
That leaves a lot of us suddenly with
allies in places that we didn't think we
were going to have allies.
And it's sort of unfortunate in one way
because you want to always think that
you can sort of stay home and fix
things.
I got to pop the bubble.
But at the moment I find my allies who
certainly are libertarians on the right,
I think I can,
you know,
be allies and a lot of ways with Ben
Shapiro,
even though we have differences on the
margins with abortion and some of that
other stuff.
Um,
but I don't see at the moment from when
we're taping this right now.
I just don't see any hope in the short
term for the Democrats.
My hope is that this thing implodes that
they get probably half to get crushed in
the midterms,
which is not looking likely,
but that they get crushed in the
midterms.
And then they have a major course
adjustment where they go,
we've got to return to liberalism.
Sure.
And that is the answer because I believe
liberalism is the answer.
I think it's the only answer.
But if you know somebody that I should
be paying attention to,
let me know because I don't see much.
We'll keep in touch and I know we've got
a list.
I'll send you some liberals.
That one more thing I know we're about
onto.
Yeah.
What is your favorite musical and with
which musical character do you identify
the most?
Oh Man.
Yeah,
not really going for it.
I'd rather do favorite superhero movie
or something,
but a superior moving.
Let's go to that.
Well,
I was telling you during the break that
I.
I mean,
I really felt infinity war was
spectacular.
I think it was just done right.
Loki has to be dead though.
That's,
that's the key thing I want.
But I think I love Gomorrah.
She's amazing.
She's a bad ass.
But if they bring her back,
which they will bring her back,
she was killed in the process of getting
the soul stone.
So they can say that once they destroyed
the stones or whatever,
however it may be,
they could bring her back and it'll be
nice to see her back because I love her
as an actress.
I love her chemistry with everyone.
But that was a powerful me.
You can't keep killing people and
bringing them back.
That's why Loki has to be dead this
time.
Which they basically made it sound like.
Yeah.
What infinity ward did a good job with.
You know Tony.
Tony has been in Mcu for what?
Like 20 movies and he didn't die
Gomorrah.
This is her third film and I felt that I
felt that debt right here.
I hate to tell you,
but she's,
well hate to tell you or whatever.
She's good.
She's going to be alive.
But putting that aside,
musical,
you know,
I'm not a huge musical guy.
I'm not.
I know you don't want to hear that as
well as a theater guy.
Yeah.
No,
not a huge moves or girl I liked.
I liked Mama Mia is we can,
we can find some common ground.
That's what it is.
It's about
exactly what's up,
man.
We could've talked about marvel movies
and all these other.
You gave
me a lot of funny pop culture references
before we started.
You have to,
uh,
you have to break new ground.
And that's what I was trying to do here.
That's what it's all about.
I have no doubt you have a bright future
and you're probably going to be
president.
Is that where this is all leading
president of Stoneman Douglas High
School's Drama Club?
No,
because my dear friend,
uh,
she ran and she's doing a phenomenal
job.
I that no guys follow camera and on
twitter it's cameron underscore caskey.